take your high-end cocktail and marry it
to the ease of a canned beverage through
an award-winning mixologist and you've
got the perfect partnership joining me
to tell us more is renowned bartender
jeffrey morgenthaler welcome hi mercedes
thank you i'm so excited for you on this
first of all i mean we're just talking
about some of your awards that
and it's just you're astounding to have
you here is truly an honor and to tell
us about this new
line of cocktails so we we don't need to
be an award-winning mixologist like you
to create this no that's the whole point
is is now i can get more drinks and more
hands and you don't have to come to my
bar to get them i love it now you're
going to show us how to create one of
them but let's talk about this you so
now they're canned beverages and you you
take canned beverages up and off these
are classy beverages thank you yeah we
really uh designed them from the can
outwards rather than taking a
pre-existing cocktail and kind of
shoving it into the candy right you know
so so what do we have we have three
different varieties let's talk about
some of these this is uh this is a gin
ricky um which is gin lime juice and a
little bit of fresh mint oh
it's sparkling it's effervescent it's
just like jumping out of the can and
it's it's uh perfect ice cold okay
that sounds really good i like the mint
aspect but this one has my heart because
that's got citrus in it
what is this one absolutely that is the
paloma so uh paloma is a pretty classic
cocktail with tequila and grapefruit
soda as you know
we
sort of reverse engineered grapefruit
soda uh from fresh ingredients for the
can that sounds amazing and and the
alcohol is already in here right alcohol
is in there and these are made with real
spirits this isn't like a malt beverage
now you're creating this last one this
sounds amazing bourbon renewal this is
my baby i've been making this drink now
for over 20 years
and
is it a lot is it a complicated recipe
what are you doing you know it really is
uh think whiskey sour
sweetened with just a little bit of
creme de cassis so this is a black
currant liqueur okay so it's just got a
touch of sweetness uh it's a real sort
of like berry vibe
um
and it just brings a whole layer well
should we try it and find out can we try
it let's open that up okay so i love
that i don't need to have this item i
don't need to have fresh lemons i don't
need to have any of that i can just open
the can up okay would you like something
i would love to okay all right let's
let's check this out oh the
effervescence i'm loving it i probably
filled my glass up too high
oh well
and these are these are all under nine
percent alcohol so you can't fill your
glass up too bad smells really good oh
my gosh okay let's take
oh my gosh
that that is this that in a can thank
you i feel so fancy like drinking this
high-end cocktail that i just put in
there put a little bit of ice in there
or drink it straight out of the can it's
actually really good okay thank you can
i finish the whole can
where do people get this
my boss is like no do not
get them at your local independent
retailer
that is some good stuff and what's next
for you
working on a bar now that ours closed
working on another one up in portland
and that's all i can say oh you heard it
here first this is great stuff check it
out these are oh man i thought i thought
this was going to be the one but i think
i love this oh jillian we're going to
finish these i'm going to send it over
to you